of things that are trending as the tokyo
olympics continue there was a stunning
upset for the u.s gymnastics star simone
biles
she pulled out of the women's team
gymnastics final today
after only competing in the vault saying
that she wasn't right mentally
well today we are checking in with lacey
alderson wellness expert and mental
health counselor
to talk about mental health and its
importance behind
simone biles exit lacey welcome thank
you for joining us today
i think so many of us were completely
shocked by this announcement why
are we surprised when our favorite
athletes come
forward sharing their mental health
struggles
our athletes in general we have on such
a high you know plat plane if you will
they mean everything to us and to learn
that they suffer from mental illness
just like the rest of the population i
think it's staggering for a lot of us to
really get our heads around
35 percent of the athletic community
it's an estimate
um really do struggle with mental health
depression anxiety
addiction issues so they're a lot like
us in so many other ways
a lot of these athletes already feel the
pressure but do you think that
covid restrictions are also contributing
to this
i think a lot of us really don't realize
that these athletes are used to having
their parents in the stands they're used
to having their friends there
and to be able to go through some of
these things alone and not have that
physical support a hug a high five
i'm somebody to basically come home to
at the end of of you know your specific
trade it's something that's going to hit
them a little bit harder it's going to
be much more of an isolating experience
so yes
i think covert restrictions absolutely
do take a toll do you think
these olympians that we're seeing today
are different than the olympians in the
years past
it's actually a really good question i
think that if you are going to struggle
with mental illness and be open about it
2021 is the best time to do it there
have been so many trailblazers before
simone biles we've had
naomi osaka we've had michael phelps
we've had ronda rousey all these amazing
athletes that have
been able to come before these olympians
to be able to say hey listen i'm
suffering too
i'm struggling and i'm going to get help
i wanted to bring up something that's a
little off
topic but still in the same realm let's
talk about marc-andre fleury a lot
of vegas golden knights fans are
completely
heartbroken today uh how do we deal with
that
it almost feels like we're losing a
member of our family
because mercedes we are and mark andre
fleury is literally a part of our family
right i mean since october one this
family's been so special to us
and now we're literally losing them it
feels like morning
so it's interesting to see um the
community's response a lot of people are
very angry right now about this decision
they feel blindsided they feel
personally hurt and those feelings
really come from ultimately
being disappointed so i think we have to
make some room
for that loss for what lies ahead and
remain hopeful but definitely be sad be
angry have the conversations you need to
have
to make it that you can process this
information and process the loss for
not only the nights but our whole
community there's a lot to process there
lacey
thank you so much for your time you
always
have such great advice we appreciate it
let's take things